Every so often, the Foundation gets a tip
about an anomalous object rather than discovering
it through their global surveillance network.
Tip-offs aren’t common, because few people
know how to even get in contact with the Foundation
directly, but when they do, it’s always
a relief.
The agents and Mobile Task Forces that are
sent to investigate and retrieve possible
SCPs usually walk in blind - there’s no
telling what they might find.
But when a tip-off, report, or informant from
one of the Groups of Interest comes in and
spills the beans, the brave front-liners of
the Foundation usually have a slightly better
idea of what they’re tackling.
Usually.
Sometimes they get complacent and end up underestimating
or going in underprepared.
And when that happens…
well, the consequences can be disastrous.
Way back in 1990, the Foundation received
an unexpected tip-off from one of its contacts
based on the island of Hong Kong.
It wasn’t much - just a location and a general
description of the effects told discreetly
over the phone.
The contact was one of some fifty thousand
Chinese residents of a particular neighborhood
in Hong Kong – the infamous Kowloon Walled
City.
The city was originally a Chinese military
fort on the island of Hong Kong.
When the island was sold to the British Empire
at the end of the 19th century, the fort was
converted into massive, densely packed apartment
buildings and quickly became an enclave for
the Chinese.
When Japan occupied Hong Kong during WW2,
tens of thousands of ethnic Chinese on the
island took refuge in the massive apartment
blocks of the slum.
There was no government, no police, no laws
– the dozens of floors were controlled by
gangs and drug dealers, but it was better
than being homeless.
And of course, the residents were incredibly
suspicious of any authorities.
You can imagine why the Foundation was reticent
to send some of their best men into a densely-packed
civilian area that was likely to be hostile
to their presence.
Their contact informed them that the anomalous
object was a small relic of some kind with
strange, terrifying powers.
It was located deep in the heart of the Walled
City, and it might even be responsible for
the very city’s existence.
Foundation command considered that the alternative
was letting fifty-thousand people reside inside
of an uncontained anomaly, and decided that
they’d send someone to investigate.
They picked troops from Mobile Task Force
Zeta-9, the Mole Rats.
The Mole Rats are some of the Foundation’s
most trustworthy operatives – they’re
a task force specially trained and equipped
to operate in dangerous and anomalous environments,
particularly those that are underground or
underwater.
Whether it’s an undersea cave system or
an endless, claustrophobic basement, the Mole
Rats perform search, rescue, containment,
and even recovery in these terrifying places.
They seemed like the natural fit to be the
ones to lead the expedition, while exploring
and finding out what in the world had caused
the Kowloon Walled City.
The team landed in Hong Kong on June 3rd,
led by one Gordon Richards, a member of Zeta-9.
He kept an extensive personal diary, as most
agents do - and from it, the Foundation was
able to learn what SCP-184 truly was.
The first impression Richards had of the Walled
City while exploring it with his partner,
Henry, was pure disgust.
It was a densely-packed slum that was largely
made of trash and refuse, covered in filth
and stinking to high heaven.
The suits that the team wore protected them
from any hazardous material or danger, but
it was still a vile experience moving through
the cramped streets and corridors of the ghetto.
At one point, Richards’ partner was walking
through an area piled knee-deep in trash when
the floor gave out, dumping him into a cesspool.
On their first day, they learned practically
nothing from the locals.
The residents of the Walled City were suspicious
of outsiders.
They’d either avoid the agents or throw
trash and insults at them from afar in Cantonese
and sometimes Mandarin.
But Richards did manage to catch whispers
in some of the bars that peppered the city
– there was something strange in the center
of the mass, something that sounded nothing
short of anomalous.
Foundation agents assisted Hong Kong Police
Officers
in conducting raids overnight, hoping to find
more information.
In the morning, the Mole Rats returned to
investigate, and found the first evidence
of something actually anomalous affecting
several of the tiny apartments.
From the outside, they looked like the same
ragged shanties as the other hundred-square-foot
apartments, but they were far too big from
the inside.
Henry had seemed spooked since his fall into
the cesspit the day prior - the other agents
tried talking to him but it didn’t help
much, and he spent most of the day in a strange
fugue, muttering to himself.
Richards told him to knock it off, but never
reported it, feeling bad for the new kid.
The next day would be spent in the sewers,
trying to find a direct route to the center
of the city where this object was being held.
Richards went into the sewer with a fellow
agent but found nothing except more waste
and filth.
They were unable to get on the radio with
the rest of the team inside the actual building
until they came out early the next day, after
spending almost a full day underground.
They were quickly pulled out by other agents
and briefed: while they had been in the sewers,
Henry and another agent had been exploring
the central portion of the city, That’s
when they were rushed by an angry mob.
Dozens of people attacked before they even
had a chance to retaliate – both were viciously
beaten, but Henry was dragged off deeper into
the city and the other agent was injured during
his retreat back to base.
When they could no longer hear Henry’s screams
on the radio, several armed agents rushed
in to extract him.
That’s when they heard Henry’s radio again.
He was screaming and rambling incoherently,
sounding like he was hallucinating about the
city being alive when the radio cut out again.
The search team was shocked by the sight of
Henry rounding the corner, running at full
pace and screaming without his helmet.
He pushed an agent aside before smashing right
through one of the weak, thin garbage walls,
falling six stories onto a pile of metal scrap.
The sight was gruesome, and it took them hours
to recover his body.
Zeta-9 was done screwing around - they were
going to round up the city’s leaders and
find this anomaly before it killed anyone
else.
Over the next day or so, the agents, aided
by the Hong Kong PD, rounded up many of the
city elders and community leaders, pulling
them from their apartments and shanties.
Zeta-9 worked on interrogating them for information,
while Richards provided the muscle.
The first person they pulled was a member
of the Chinese Triads, one of the gangs that
functionally ran that city.
When he didn’t cooperate, the agents broke
his legs, and he suddenly became a lot more
talkative.
He explained that the anomaly was called “the
Builder” and no one quite knew where it
came from or how it worked.
The closest he had ever come was standing
guard outside rooms while it “worked”,
and that the city elders would know more.
When he brushed off Henry’s death, Richards
broke his jaw.
The next person was an ancient-looking Chinese
man named Long Wen, one of the city’s reclusive
elders.
He was indomitable - no matter what Richards
did, he wouldn’t give in under abuse or
torture.
But when one of the agents suggested that
Zeta-9 pay a visit to his family, he immediately
opened up.
He told them that The Builder was kept in
an old temple that the City had grown around.
It was highly secret and only a few people
could look upon it without going mad - he
had tried to show Henry so that the Foundation
wouldn’t take it away, but obviously, that
hadn’t gone quite as planned.
When asked where it was, Long-Wen explained
that as soon as the agents had arrived, they
had moved it deep inside the city, where no
one would be able to get to it.
But Zeta-9 took that as a challenge - tomorrow,
they were moving into the city’s temple,
and not coming out without that anomaly.
Richards and the rest of the Mole Rats prepared
themselves for the expedition over the following
few days.
They were going to venture deep into the heart
of the Kowloon Walled City, far away from
any supply lines or external Foundation support.
They made sure they went in heavily armed,
with their suits life-support enabled, and
prepared for every possibility.
They departed on June 8th, heading straight
into the belly of the city, where Henry had
been abducted by the mob.
At first, it seemed strange but not overtly
anomalous – the same dingy, damp apartments
full of garbage.
But eventually, they came upon what they were
looking for – a small, tiny temple, Buddhist
in style and design.
It was made of stone and wood, with a small
Buddha statue out front.
It was the only thing that looked remotely
out of place, otherwise surrounded by shanties
and cobbled-together homes.
In the words of the great David Byrne, this
must be the place.
At first, it was nothing new – the temple
was too big on the inside, but it was nothing
they hadn’t seen in the hundred other rooms
in this massive building.
A small shrine, a few seats here and there,
altars.
But then Richards and the other agents noticed
something – a sliding door, built into the
wall of the tiny ten-foot temple.
It made no sense – a door would exit out
into the apartment right next door.
When they opened it, they found… a hallway
leading deeper into the structure, made of
the same wood and rice paper that the temple
was constructed from.
It was long, too – at this point, they should’ve
been deep into the other apartments in the
building, More so than any other room they
had checked before.
As they travelled down the corridor, they
found more sliding doors lining the walls.
More temple rooms, altars, and meditation
chambers, all recreated and rearranged by
the anomaly.
It was like someone built twelve whole temples
inside this one tiny structure, expanding
ever inward.
That must’ve been why they called this thing
the Builder, whatever it was.
The Mole Rats knew that this place was bound
to be gigantic, and set up a small base camp
in the original temple, to stop any of the
residents from getting the jump on them.
Then they got their suits sealed, their equipment
rigged up, and went to work exploring the
various corridors, hallways, and temples that
had grown out of this anomaly.
At first, it was simple and repetitive, but
things started to get strange after the sixth
hour of exploration.
The rooms began to thin out until the Mole
Rats were mostly exploring uninterrupted,
long hallways made of bamboo and rice paper.
They came upon a room with something inside
it – another meditation chamber, but this
time a small bronze Buddha statue was placed
in the center of the room.
It was the size of Richards’ fist, and his
team collected a sample before moving to the
sliding door at the rear of the room.
They opened it up and exited right back into
a meditation room with a tiny, fist-sized
Buddha in the center.
For a second, they thought they had been transported
backward, but this Buddha didn’t have any
samples taken out of it.
It was an identical copy of the room they
had just entered through.
Strange, but not unexpected – they didn’t
bother taking a sample and moved to the next
room.
Which was also a meditation chamber with a
Buddha in the middle.
All in all, they found eighty-three rooms
in a row that were identical copies of that
one chamber with the Buddha, connected by
the sliding doors.
After that experience, and a few hallways
later, they came upon another familiar sight
– a perfect recreation of the original altar
room they had entered into the temple from,
but with one difference.
Rather than being made out of planks of wood
and stone, this room seemed to be carved from
a single, massive piece of wood with no seams
or breaks.
There were no tool marks anywhere, and it
looked as though it’d been somehow naturally
formed.
But they did find a small collection of documents,
written in Chinese, in the corner.
They scanned the documents and sent digital
copies back to HQ.
The agents at the base responded – the anomaly
had been designated SCP-184, and the templegoers
seemed to think it was a gift from God.
They allowed people to bring it into their
apartments for a small payment and let it
grow the space.
Zeta-9 resolved to grab it and get out before
it could expand the temple any further.
They bunked down for the night to get some
sleep.
The next morning, they continued moving through
the temple until they hit a branch in the
road and split the team.
Richards picked one hallway and set out on
his own, climbing upwards.
The walls in this section of the temple were
irregular – they were undulating, wavy.
The wood and rice had given way to hard stone
hallways.
Richards slipped into one of the rooms to
rest for a while, and found that all the furniture
was made of beautiful green jade, despite
being wonderfully soft.
He rested on the jade bed for a while before
continuing on.
He wrote in the journal that he didn’t feel
well - disconnected from the environment,
not like a usual mission.
One of his team members had died, and the
environment itself felt hostile.
Without anyone else to talk to, he was thinking
too much.
But it was just nerves.
He signed the journal and kept moving.
For the next hours and days, Richards continued
on.
His suit’s ability to make food and water
was running low.
As he moved through the stone temple, he saw
something out of the corner of his eye that
wasn’t there when he looked again.
He heard voices that couldn’t possibly be
there.
He’d been climbing for so long he’d lost
track of time.
While climbing up the shaft, he finally saw
light and darted through - only to enter a
room filled with lit candles, not sunlight.
Enraged, he smashed them all with his helmet,
breaking the helmet to pieces.
He sat and cried for a while, before dropping
something down the shaft to see how far it
was to the bottom - but never heard it hit
the floor.
He set his jaw – Screw containment, he had
to find this thing and utterly destroy it.
The next time he saw something, it was days
later.
His food and water had run out when he had
found a hall filled with doors lining every
surface.
They all led back into the wall, but he noticed
he was bleeding – the floor wasn’t carpet,
but razor-sharp stone pinpricks that had shredded
the boots of his suit to ribbons, along with
his feet.
He returned to climbing after patching himself
up a little.
He had to kill this thing, somehow.
The rest of the entries are disparate and
unsigned.
One of the rare coherent ones revealed that
he was at the top of the shaft, at something
called the ‘hall to forever’, filled with
light, and that he was ‘going to kill the
heart’.
Around the time these entries were written,
the other members of Zeta-9 felt the temple
shaking and cracking, growing unstable.
They quickly evacuated, minutes before they
saw the interior of the temple collapsing
in on itself.
The entire expanded area collapsed into the
tiny space of the original altar room.
Through the rubble, the members of Zeta-9
found Richards’ journal along with a tiny
metal object - matching the descriptions of
SCP-184.
They never did find Richards’ body.
He went missing during the recovery, presumed
Killed in Action.
After it was brought back to base, Foundation
researchers went to work on it.
It was a tiny metal statuette in the shape
of a dodecahedron.
The metal it was made from was unknown, but
tests revealed that it was magnetic and hard
as brass.
Experiments followed.
They discovered that when they put SCP-184
inside an enclosed structure, like a room
or building or even a cardboard box, it would
expand the interior dimensions without making
it grow larger.
The effect was powerful - the rooms it was
tested in would grow by hundreds of square
meters every day.
At first, it just moves the walls out, making
the room up to three times bigger than it
is – but after that, it gets strange.
During a test in a small bedroom in a suburban
home, after it grew the room three times in
floor space, it began to create entirely new
rooms.
The researchers suddenly went in to find three
kitchens, six bedrooms, a dozen bathrooms,
and tens of closets.
They were all fully furnished – SCP-184
was capable of copying materials from the
rest of the building, but not particularly
well.
The appliances in the kitchens were made of
wood or rock, and the ‘furniture’ was
limited to glass sofas and chairs.
The rooms were oddly-shaped as the house went
on – at first they were oval, but the deeper
bedrooms were pentagonal and even star-shaped.
They even found one bathroom that was a perfect
sphere.
Some of the doors led right into an empty
wall, and the hallways changed in size and
shape and led around into themselves like
a labyrinth.
The researchers quickly removed SCP-184 from
the house and tried to figure out how to contain
this thing.
If there’s one thing the Foundation is good
at, it’s locking things up in boxes - but
locking this thing up in a box is the most
dangerous thing they could possibly do.
One researcher had an “out of the box”
idea.
SCP-184 was placed between two electromagnets,
which kept it floating in mid-air and made
it impossible to pull away.
That solved half the problem - and the Foundation
knew exactly where to put it without enclosing
it in a space.
Only a few years after the events of Zeta-9s
recovery, the Hong Kong government finally
demolished the massive Kowloon Walled City,
replacing it with an open park commemorating
the site, with many statuaries and relics
from the City.
The Foundation made sure they were able to
install SCP-184’s electromagnets as another
statuary inside a gazebo, finally containing
SCP-184 right where it had been all along.
Be it ever so humble, there’s no place like
eternally recursive home.
Now go check out “SCP-3008 - Trapped in
IKEA” and “SCP-2427 - A Thing Full of
Stuff” for more anomalous locations you
might never escape!